we challenged ourselves to ensure doom
lived up to its incredible legacy and we
thank you our fans for making the doom
launch such a tremendous success it's
been amazing to watch and hear from the
millions of players enjoying the many
aspects of the game from those of you
gunning for the perfect run through the
campaign to others constantly testing
their skills in multiplayer you continue
to inspire our team last year we told
you we wanted to put the power of
creation in the hands of every player
through do snap map allowing for an
endless stream of new gameplay and in
the coming months we're excited to be
supporting doom snap map with free
updates and even more ways to play will
be delivering new construction modules
including hell visual things as well as
new props objects weapons and items
while creators can look forward to new
logic options and functionality like the
ability to create true single player
experiences with features like the
popular weapon wheel found in the
campaign and again throughout the year
every snap map feature and update is
free for every player for multiplayer
next month will release two new modes
including a uniquely doom variant of one
flag CTF called Exodus as well as an
all-new multi-zone capture and hold mode
called sector later this summer will
turn up the heat with the release of
three free for all modes including
classic deathmatch these modes will be
free to all players and playable on any
existing or future maps also next month
fans can look forward to our first
premium doom DLC pack unto the evil the
first DLC pack includes three new
multiplayer maps offering Cataclysm and
ritual a new playable demon called the
harvester a new gun equipment item armor
sets taunts and more
just a month passed since our launch we
hope you've only scratched the surface
of fun we packed into the game and we
can't wait to give you even more ways to
compete create play and fight like hell
thank you